what up space fan goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the latest and insane
developments in the demon Slayers story
if you want to keep seeing deep inside
your closet on this channel make sure to
drop a like to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and ring
that notification about because if you
don't you won't get notified when you
demon slayer videos drop for more demon
center content and crucial updates on
the new movie and seasons make sure to
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar keep in mind there will be
manga spoilers in this video we're going
to be discussing the latest chapter
chapter 179 of the manga so you've been
warned now without further ado let's
jump into it this chapter is called
feelings for elder brother feelings for
younger brother
it's interesting how much of a focus
there has been on brothers lately the
last few chapters were closely focused
on yuuichi the strongest Demon Slayer in
history and his less talented brother
who became upper moon one kokeshi bow as
koku shiva was dying he revisited his
conflicted emotions about his brother he
was jealous and said that he hated his
brother but yet he kept the flute his
brother treasured showing that he too
cared about you at Ichi just as your
Ichi cared about him Kukui bow couldn't
completely discard his humanity like he
wanted to he wasn't the monster that he
tried to convince himself he was but
with this chapter Coco she boys no
longer taking center stage his story has
concluded and now in this chapter we are
dealing with the aftermath of the battle
we are dealing with two different sets
of brothers namely Ganga and sana me and
Mui tuna taquito and his older twin
brother
Yuichiro topito the latter two are
actually descendants of Kosovo's so that
adds even more significance to their
relationship anyways we start to chapter
with Yomi telling sana me to stop
attacking Coco she bow since he is no
longer regenerating
however son of me keeps attacking Yomi
has to physically stop him then yo may
figures out that sana me is unconscious
even though he's still moving I guess
you could say he pulled his any tool
after he gets sending me under control
Yomi looks at the conditions of ganya
and Mui Chiu Kenya's first thoughts are
not for himself but for his brother and
Mui Cheeto
Yomi says they are alive and that it's
okay but Ganga seems to know that mu
Ichiro is not alright he tells yo me to
tend to him gaya says he's okay so Yomi
should focus on helping mu Ichiro X
Jenna is not okay at all he's dying and
yet he is so selfless when we were first
introduced again yet he seemed like a
jerk as did sanity
they were the jerk brothers however the
more we get to know these characters the
more it seems like their jerk personas
were largely superficial underneath
their rough exteriors they were deeply
compassionate and caring on the inside
for destroyed philosophers death was the
ultimate test how people handle dying
revealed their true character some might
go out kicking and screaming and
lamenting how cruel their faith is while
others might leave the world in a more
honourable way Kenya proves to be the
latter just like gran Goku was man I
love that firebender butt back to ganya
Kenya does not fight the reality of the
situation or the man that he gets help
he is not selfish at all he is at
death's door and he doesn't think of
himself he wants to make sure that the
others are all right
Yomi sees that ganya's demon
regenerative powers are weakening with
this huge amount of blood loss yo me
knows that Kenya probably won't make it
and he puts his brother sana me next to
him Kenya is relieved that his still
unconscious brother is okay then yo may
goes to see my man Mui cheeto the 14
year old kid who managed to do so much
he thanks Mui cheeto yo May says that it
was thanks to him that they were able to
win remember that it was Mui Chiu nose
red blade that arguably had the biggest
effect on Coco Chivo Yomi continues to
praise Moo Ichiro even though he's dead
and probably can no longer hear what
he's saying
I respect yo made for this he tells me
to know that from the bottom of his
heart
Mui Shiro has his gratitude and respect
this is probably the greatest compliment
that the strongest pillar can give
someone he comets again on how
ridiculously young mu Ichiro was and how
despite his young age he was magnificent
to the end
Yomi promises that they'll defeat Mouzon
then he tells mutirão to be at peace and
closes his eyes we jump into the
afterlife world we've seen so often and
demons here we're dead characters or
near dead characters reunite with their
dead loved ones not surprisingly Mui
cheeto is again reunited with his older
twin brother
Yuichiro Yuichiro is another example of
a character that seemed like a jerk at
first but as it turns out he really
cared about his brother even if he
didn't always act like it
Yuichiro is crying when he sees that Mui
cheeto is that
Moochie doe who worked so hard thought
he had finally earned his brothers
praise but his brother instead
criticizes him for dying
Yuichiro wishes his fourteen-year-old
brother ran he thinks he should have let
the older guys handle it rather than
putting his young life on the line
however muay judo says that he couldn't
abandon his comrades again we get the
question of what someone's life was for
in the last chapter Coco Siebel asked
you to each sheet what his life was for
why was he born similarly now Yuichiro
is asking what muy chinos life was for
however unlike hakushi Boh Muccino has
an answer but first he mentions that his
brother died at eleven years old so he
feels sorry for him at least mutirão got
to experience out three whole years on
earth that Yuichiro didn't this is a
powerful line because it shows how
things can be framed in different ways
glass half-full or glass half-empty
style sure compared to the average
person Muccino died way earlier but
compared to his brother and many others
he had a longer time on earth than they
did and he is thankful for the years he
had rather than being regretful for the
years he didn't have Muccino reveals
that the reason he was born was to be
happy he asks his brother Yuichiro if
there wasn't even a single moment when
he too was happy the smoocher is
suggesting that even a life with one
happy moment was not a waste of life it
was a life worth living if we think back
to Coco Cibo he had happy moments as
well in fact he told us he lived a
serene life for at least 10 years even
he admitted as much so if he simply
framed things the way Mauricio did he'd
see that he didn't live for nothing he
did get to experience the miracle of
life which is reason enough for anyone
to be born Muccino explains that he had
many happy moments he was happy when he
lived with his family he was sad when
they died and he was left alone but he
eventually made friends along with those
friends came good times when he could
smile again there were countless moments
when he experienced happiness for a Muay
chiodo that was enough that was a full
life he didn't turn his eyes away or run
from anything in this way he died an
honorable death
he stayed committed to his principles
unlike Coco Cibo he doesn't regret
risking his life for his comrades
there's a lot to be said here the manga
is inviting us
compared much it was extremely short
life to his ancestor Koko she bows
extremely long life an argument is being
put for it that it's not about the
quantity of life we experience as much
as it is about the quality of life Koko
she will live for centuries and he died
not knowing what he lived for Moo Ichiro
lived a short 14 years and he died
content and fulfilled knowing exactly
what he lived for Koko Sheba wanted to
extend his life at the cost of his
principles while mucha was willing to
die for his principles kuku Shiva
couldn't be thankful for centuries worth
of living while Mui cheeto could be
extremely thankful for 14 years because
he focused on the moments of happiness
he experienced
if only Coco Chabot was willing to
reframe the way he viewed things he
could have lived a much happier life and
died a happy fulfilled man eventually
Mui Chiu and his brother make up you two
apologizes and says that he just didn't
want his brother to die that's why he
was so hard on his brother they hug and
we jump to sana be opening his eyes Sena
me sees that Kenya's body is crumbling
like a demon's ganya was in fact dying
despite all the talk about him being
fine Dania apologizes for criticizing
son and me and for always troubling him
Sunmi says that he never once troubled
him and tells him not to die he says
that Kenya can't die before him they are
both crying and you probably are too as
you read this part because it's that
touching Kenya thinks his brother for
protecting him and sunna me says that he
didn't protect them which is true in
this situation because ganya is dying
however ganya clarifies he explains at
this time he wanted to protect sana me
the way sana me protected him all these
years then he says we feel the same way
because we're brothers
they both wanted to protect each other
they would both die for each other
Kenya wants son and me to live and be
happy despite the fact that Sunday me
seem like the biggest jerk in the
beginning remember he even heard her
precious musical Kenya calls his brother
the nicest person in the world while son
of me is begging the universe not to
take his little brother away Kenya
continues to disappear he thanks his big
brother one more time before he
completely disappears son and he screams
out in anguish at the loss of his little
brother but he doesn't even have time to
properly mourn yo Mei tells him that
they have to go he needs to raise his
head because this is an old
until they defeat Musa Wow I will lie
there was some excessive water in my
eyes during this chapter especially near
the end as I mentioned before kill me
and Kakashi Bo who both had access to
the see-through world pretty much said
that these two were as good as dead
thus it makes sense that we didn't have
some crazy twist with them surviving
because that earlier part wouldn't
really make sense but at the same time
I'm pretty shocked that they actually
did this a part of me still thought that
at least Kenya might survive but no they
both died and it was emotional AF it
seems like the mangaka is really willing
to kill off characters we've grown to
know for a long time
ganya was introduced as early as chapter
6 and he died over 170 chapters later
this isn't like when people introduce a
character in a specific arc and then we
get to know them for a few chapters and
they die no this is a completely
different ballpark and I respect the
fact that the manga is willing to go
there even if I'm saddened to see the
passing of both of these characters I
also really like the way mu Ichiro's
death was framed
Jenya died a happy man as well but mu
Ichiro story was especially touching
because he's like the youngest demon
slayer he's had through a common sense
lens are really short life and yet he's
managed to find meaning in that life and
die a happy man
while koko Cibo couldn't do that even
though he lived for centuries it should
really be a lesson to us these guys are
related they have similar genes yet
there are different approaches to life
mean one a miserable monster and one a
happy hero we should think of which you
know the next time we find ourselves
complaining or framing things on
negative way this guy died at 14 and he
still found things to be grateful for
learn from him focus on the positive and
be thankful for what you've had the
pleasure to experience rather than
always finding stuff to be miserable
about like koko Cibo and that is it for
this chat to review thank you so much
for watching smash that like button if
you enjoyed it and let me know your
thoughts in the comments if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and bring that
notification belt so you actually get
notified when the next Demon Slayer
video comes out false on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar for more
content and crucial updates about the
new movie and seasons a big thank you
goes out to our patients over on patreon
who helped make videos like this one
possible I especially want to thank our
pro here to your patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson King Saul just Angel
Cruz Steelers Pablo atropos Wraith $30
beat at Karachi and Anatoly Cassatt Suki
DJ Nathanael and Matteo and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven and grata alo long autumn
Maddie back to 39 makoto-kun and yeah
boys set if you enjoy our work you can
support Mormon by going over to
patreon.com slash anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patient only discord so check out
patreon accomplished enemy out bro link
in the description if you're interested
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer and you'll still get
the same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]